[Music]
good evening welcome to Tucker Carlson
tonight as of right now Joe Biden is the
strong frontrunner for the Democratic
presidential nomination almost nobody
saw that coming we certainly didn't and
we apologize for that again and again we
told you Joe Biden would never be the
Democratic nominee we were wrong
how'd we screw that up mostly because we
don't think like Democrats think the
Republican Party is a coalition of
business interests and conservative
audio logs at its core it's about ideas
the Constitution the free market the
basic principles of Western civilization
the Democratic Party isn't like that at
all Democrats don't fixate on ideas
instead their base is a constellation of
aggrieved interest groups animated by
their hostility to traditional Americans
they may not have much in common
but they're united in their desire to
take power and redistribute the spoils
to themselves to achieve that Democrats
know they must stick together no matter
what group cohesion is the root of their
power on this show we didn't see it that
way we looked at the Democratic primary
field from the outside and we thought
the obvious is this party really gonna
nominate a guy with no program no core
beliefs and by the way who's clearly
lost it and the answer we learned last
ideas of course they are and why
wouldn't they it might work but hold on
you're probably wondering the most basic
question of all if elected president
could Joe Biden really oversee this
complex nation of 320 million people
judge for yourself he was Biden's
victory speech from last night in which
he mistook his wife of 43 years for his
sister
[Applause]
[Music]
my sister they switched on me so
apparently some practical joker hit his
wife Fuhrman cruel as a smart friend
said last night Joe Biden has spent his
entire life trying to succeed in
presidential politics now he has too bad
he's not there to enjoy it pretty funny
but to the cynical and darkly clever
people who run the Democratic Party
Biden's fading intellect is not a
handicap it's an opportunity Joe Biden
is weak and he's getting weaker ask
anyone who knows him or who's watched
him carefully over the past 50 years
Biden is noticeably more confused now
than he was even last spring when he
entered the race so why is this good
news for the Democratic establishment in
Washington well because it means they
can control him that's one reason the
other candidates were so eager to swing
in behind
Biden the instant he want to stay
tonight and the candidate with the best
shot to do it and after yesterday's vote
it is clear that candidate is my friend
and a great American Joe Biden that I'm
delighted to endorse and support
[Applause]
and it wasn't just Democrats who jumped
on board the entire so-called resistance
angry former Republicans got in
immediately bill kristol and a Navarro
Jennifer Rubin that weird little guy was
jeb Bush's spokesman back in 2016 they
were all thrilled by Biden's rise they
know that Biden will greenlight their
pointless Foreign Wars no questions
asked and then because the day couldn't
get more predictable and hilarious James
Comey himself sent a supportive tweet
quote voted in first Democratic primary
to support a party dedicated to
restoring values in the White House I
agree with Amy Klobuchar we need
candidates who care about all Americans
and will restore decency dignity to the
office there's a reason Trump fears Joe
Biden and roots for Bernie hashtag Biden
2020 all these people are happy for the
same reason Joe Biden is fading and
uncertain week leaders are vessels for
the stronger forces around them and no
force in American politics is stronger
more aggressive or better organized than
the narrow little interest groups that
comprise the Democratic coalition
there's a reason Governor Ralph Northam
of Virginia swung so far from the center
after he was caught wearing Klan robes
northern was badly wounded by that he
was on the brink of resigning you'll
remember and then Democratic interest
groups swooped in and took control of
his administration now the northern
administration looks nothing like it
once did they're in charge
is it fun q one of the first things Joe
Biden did after winning the South
Carolina primary on Saturday was pledged
to put beta or ork in charge of his gun
policy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna guarantee you this amount last
year say to this guy you're gonna take
care of the gun follow with me you're
gonna be the one who leads his every
beta is quote gonna take care of the gun
problem how exactly is beta gonna do
that well a work has promised to cease
the rifles of law-abiding Americans by
force with armed federal agents if
necessary and that wasn't a throwaway
line he said it repeatedly that is the
most extreme position on gun control
ever articulated in American politics
it's now Joe Biden's position because
it's the position of the powerful
Democratic interest groups that control
him in other words don't expect a Biden
presidency to be moderate not because
Joe Biden himself is some kind of
wild-eyed extremist he's clearly not
that he's a doddering old man who grins
a lot but Biden is infinitely malleable
he assumes the form of whatever
surroundings he finds himself in like an
invertebrate here is revealing that
actually he's just as southern as old
Colonel Sanders just give him a white
suit and a string tie the Democrats
nominate me I believe we can beat Donald
Trump we can meet Donald Trump cut the
talk in Delaware what you're looking at
is a man willing to save virtually
anything hard-eyed extremists in the
party will use Biden as their instrument
from the first day and not just on guns
on every issue immigration health care
taxes judges esoteric social issues so
bizarre you didn't know they existed Joe
Biden is 77 years old if elected he'd be
78 on inauguration day that's almost 10
years older than Ronald Reagan was when
he was first sworn in Biden is acutely
aware of this that's why he's always
talking about push-ups and challenging
other men to fistfights he's insecure
and that insecurity makes Biden
susceptible to the worst people in
democratic politics now you may be
afraid of the 28 year old nihilists
currently trying to reorder American
society and you should be but Joe Biden
is absolutely terrified of them
he doesn't understand exactly what their
but he knows they are the future and he
is not and for that reason he's willing
to do whatever they ask you can expect
transgendered Samoans week to become a
federal holiday in his first term and a
whole lot more after that Biden doesn't
care about the details of policy he
doesn't even know the difference he just
doesn't want to fall behind so what are
the political lessons of what happened
last night well the first is that the
Democratic establishment is far stronger
than the Republican establishment
not to mention far bigger it's in a
different category from what the right
has the extends far beyond for cable
news shows a cluster of DC think tanks
and a few low circulation magazines
we're almost through the first term of
the Trump administration and Democrats
still operate virtually every lever of
power in this country they control
finance big business the tech sector the
news media of course academia the vast
federal bureaucracy and we're including
in that unfortunately the Pentagon and
the intelligence and law enforcement
agencies every power center in America
is a raid against Donald Trump and we
would adds that list the government of
Communist China which would badly like
to return to the compliant American
leadership of yesterday all of these
groups will be working tirelessly for
Joe Biden they'll use whatever tools
they possess some of them public many
not above all they'll have the media
which needless to say is already playing
it's proscribed role what a night it has
been for Joe Biden what a race it's been
unbelievable I took a nap because I knew
that I would be up late and I woke up
and I thought I was still dreaming it
was like a dream like a dream like a
beautiful dream by November they'll be
telling you that Joe Biden is an
internationally ranked chess champion
who can cure baldness many people will
believe them because that's the thing
about propaganda it works that's why
they do it Republicans should be very
concerned about this look at the
Democratic turnout numbers from last
night they were historic in some places
they seemed to defy physics what does
that suggest it suggests there are an
awful lot of infuriated Democrats out
there they're not in the mood for
compromise they're apt to believe
anything including that Joe Biden can
beat orange Satan and solve their
personal problems
don't expect Bernie Sanders to stand in
the way of Joe Biden not for long anyway
Sanders plays the maverick but it's
pretty clear he doesn't have the stomach
to buck his own party Hillary Clinton's
DNC rigged the primaries against him
four years ago but Sanders still
dutifully endorsed her campaign for her
once she inevitably won the nomination
just today just hours after he lost his
final chance at the White House
Sanders refused to call Joe Biden what
he is a corporate shill tasked with
dragging the party back to 2009
instead Sanders went out of his way to
praise the longtime puppet of the credit
card companies as a man of high
character and I like Joe Joe is a decent
guy and I do not want this campaign to
degenerate into a Trump type effort
where we're attacking each other where
it's personal attacks that is the last
thing this country wants yeah that's not
how you get elected president and it
doesn't look like Bernie will be elected
president like so many true believer
Sanders is more comfortable losing than
winning it's hard to imagine him
throwing as seen at the Milwaukee
convention to prevent the Obama
restoration which is what this is with
Bloomberg out and Warren humiliated
there is nothing left in American
politics to stop Joe Biden's ascent to
the Democratic nomination and domination
in the party so get ready for Joe Biden
he's more threatening than he looks